qui comme 79 % des canadiennes estiment
que le sexe est primordial pour la bonne
santé d'un couple avant natation
canadienne à où il va très bien d'accord
vous benhaim up à beinheim leur bd mais
je me force à me choquait ménage moi
c'est moi qui avais times c'est ma
grande soeur il a une je la vois je suis
chaud et il me fait que c'est important
il est à 4 encore autour de la culotte
et ça va dit non mais ça fait partie de
la bonne santé du couple c'est à la
voile à l'amitié l'amour asmar dos et le
voilà qui comme des cadeaux qui nous ont
été données pour pas un rond
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai papa beaucoup
pas à pas pour jean-michel alors qui
comme 79 % des canadiennes pense que le
sexe est primordial pour la bonne santé
d'un mail c'est un vrai sondage castaldi
alors vous alors il pas de la bonne
sortie mais avec le peut-être mariage
mais c'est derrière moi quelle est la
fréquence sexuelle j'en ai fait non ce
qu'il faut surtout être accord dans un
court via des coupes houllier le sexe
n'est pas une chose importante je pense
qu isabelle si elle lui réclame mais pas
une fois par semaine par les quotas elle
ne réclamerait pas elle s'en foutrait
complètement macéra elle pourrait passer
une semaine deux semaines trois semaines
elle pourrait passer un siècle le sac
simple avec mon mari est beaucoup plus
importante ma demande à moi mais en
revanche s'il ne me faisait pas rire
le rire donc ce qui vous fait dire non
politisée rire brassard des acteurs pour
nous honnêtement il n'a rien à leur
envier
[Applaudissements]
79% des cadettes i dames la caroline ont
sans doute un peu c'est indissociable de
la santé du couple et d'ailleurs vous
remarquerez à part les hypocrites et les
mythos dès qu'on commence à ne plus
faire l'amour dans un couple c'est
termine à dos dans l'année j'allais voir
la maison c'est pas vrai si tu m'aimes
tu aurais par des embrouilles avec ça
des fois quand on embauche tu crois tu
fais avec une boîte à outils sans
briller que ça va j'ai ramené la coupe
du oui alors dans la boue de longwy
comme les repas trois fois par jour bah
oui je la laisserai non je suis
absolument d'accord
après comme disait isa sandales allongée
de la longévité du couple au sénat je
croyais à 600 fois que c'est non mais
parfois ce qui passe par dessus enfin le
sexe le rire latendresse a su a beaucoup
plus fondamentaux grenelle à kelly en
coulisses et laqué dit à l'antenne en
coulisses et celle attendre
alors qu'ils disaient et je pense que ça
s'applique au sexe aussi la beauté ça
apporte pas à manger
ouais c'est vrai ça aide à digérer a
battu 6-3 en parlant de beauté gilles
verdez ou non fait pas partie des 79 %
des canadiens se trouve que c'est pas
totalement indispensable d'accord on
peut on peut sans c'est pas vital pour
un couple
kelly moi je pense que quand deux êtres
son amoureux mois ferme en amoureux bah
en fait l'amour c'est génial je suis
celle question ça ne pose pas rue bon
d'accord mais pas besoin de toi
elle a pas besoin et je quand deux aides
sont amoureuses génial ils peuvent ne
pas faire l'amour non mais pas amoureux
je pourrais être amoureux d'une meuf
rien faire avec elle et d'un garçon est
sérieux non vraiment je suis moi la
bonne question pendant combien de temps
à mes pendant toute la vie pendant
quatre jours la famille oui la
complicité le rire c'est très important
dort pas trop vite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et comme 79 % des canadiens bien sûr que
c'est très important et c'est d'autant
mieux une fois qu'on s'est un peu
embrouillé donc parfois c'est moi
[Rires]